[Music]
today we have another
case of a daily cancellation inception
where we respond to somebody responding
to me in this case it's jamie raines who
uh wikipedia tells me is an english
youtuber with over 900 000 subscribers a
research psychologist and lgbt advocate
reigns has a phd in psychology and has
disturbingly quote conducted research
into the sexual response of transgender
men
reigns is also a self-professed quote
unquote trans man
um there have been many youtube
responses to the trailer for my film
what is a woman also many responses on
other platforms including on twitter
where the primary response from the left
on twitter has been to mass report it
and try so far unsuccessfully to get
pulled from the site so i'm getting like
i'm getting these email notifications
about reports people reporting the
trailer
you know multiple times a day
but i'm choosing rains to respond to
because this is a channel with more
subscribers than i have and somebody
with um
much more formal education than i have
so nobody can accuse me of punching down
not that there's anything wrong with
punching down mind you i'm a firm
believer that one should punch in
whichever direction needs to be punched
but we'll focus here for now the video
is uh over 10 minutes long so we won't
be able to pick it apart piece by piece
but we'll watch enough to get the point
surely i mean this phd psychologist and
lgbt activist will be able to swiftly
debunk the entire premise of my film and
utterly humiliate me in the process
i'm just a transphobe with a high school
diploma after all
shouldn't be much of a challenge so
we'll see how our friend
jamie raines does
it's called what is a woman from the
daily wire which i think i've heard of
made by somebody or involving heavily
somebody called matt walsh
[Music]
what is a woman immediately is he
wearing a sandwich board that says what
is a woman okay
can you tell me that
[Music]
oh you're at the women's march you must
have some idea please if one person can
tell me what a woman is you are not here
for women we ask you to leave what is
that what is that oh wow so a dude going
to a woman's march and going up to women
and asking them to define what a woman
is and probably acting like it's some
big gotcha moment yeah that's
interesting oh let's not forget the
sandwich board i mean what definition
was he looking for one based off of
genitals and reproductive organs that's
a little bit very narrow and not exactly
great to boil people down to their parts
okay well first of all jamie
how do you know i'm a dude i don't i
didn't tell you that
that was not that was not said
so where'd you get that from
and yeah it is a gotcha moment
in fact if people are marching in a
women's march and holding signs and
chanting slogans claiming that women are
under attack and being oppressed and yet
they have absolutely no idea what a
woman is and can't begin to define the
term then yes
that's a gotcha moment as it reveals the
inherent absurdity and incoherence of
their worldview but it's not a gotcha
moment that i engineer okay i'm not
backing anybody into a corner
all i did was
walk up to them and ask them what the
words they're using mean
that's a fair question in fact that's
the fairest question you can ever ask
anyone is when they're using words to
say what do you mean by that how could
that be an unfair question
if it becomes a gotcha moment for you
that only shows just how totally vapid
and ridiculous your ideology is as for
what kind of definition i'm looking for
well to start with i'd like a definition
some kind of definition
let's just get a definition on the table
first and then we can debate whether
it's the right or wrong one but you guys
won't put any definition at all on the
table
you act like the word has no meaning at
all like it's just a bunch of arbitrary
gibberish and yet you continue to use
the word
and uh and you
and you expect us all to know what it
means or to know what you mean when you
use it so again is it a gotcha yes it
certainly is
but i didn't get you you got yourself
[Music]
all from the controversial mind of matt
walsh i'm a husband i'm a father of four
i host a talk show i give speeches i
write books i like to make sense of
things a woman is not anything in
particular there is not one particular
thing it could be many things to many
people some women have penises right
some men have vaginas i like scented
candles i've watched sex in the city
yeah how do i know if i'm a woman oh
dear god what is he doing why is he
making this did you just show a
compilation of people saying it can't be
boiled down to one thing some women do
have penises like trans women some men
do have vaginas like some trans men and
your responses are like scented candles
is that what makes a woman
i don't know does it mean you tell me
because a second ago you said that a
woman can't be defined by her parts
now you're saying that having an
interest in feminine things
also doesn't make you a woman so what
does jamie
you've declared that neither interests
nor body parts define a woman which
would seem to indicate that you have a
solid idea in your head as to what does
define a woman and yet you have yet to
provide that definition what if i decide
that my love of scented candles makes me
a woman after all i'm not just talking
about the manly sense okay like like uh
leather or bonfire or something i can go
with a lavender candle okay that's how
girly the candles can get sometimes
and if i say that makes me a woman who
are you to say that i'm wrong
you can only just dismiss my scented
candle based definition if you have some
other objective definition in mind but
if you don't
if you have no idea what a woman is then
for all you know no a woman is truly
just anyone who's purchased a scented
candle at any point in their life
that definition is at least better than
the definition you're offering because
you aren't offering any
you're not a scientist you're not a
gender studies major no how do you know
that you're a man i guess because i got
a dick
a journey to discover the truth the
truth about mom
the truth about what a woman is it's
right there in the title
how are you confused already that's what
this is about try to keep up jaime
can a man become a woman
i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that women only
know what women are
can a man become a woman that's a silly
question because trans women are not men
who become women they are women who
happen to be trans just like trans men
are not women who become men we're men
who happen to be trans at least ask the
right questions
well this is this is shocking
i'm appalled
jamie are you suggesting that gender is
not fluid
like ninety percent of people on tick
tock identify as gender fluid do they
not exist
does tick-tock not exist are you saying
their identities are not valid are you
marginalizing gender fluid people
because in fact according to your
worldview a man can absolutely become a
woman an individual could identify as a
man one day and a woman the next
so in fact an individual could identify
as a man one minute and a woman the next
and each of those identities are valid
and true right isn't that what you think
if you are whatever you identify as and
you identify as a woman after having
identified as a man
that would mean that you became a woman
you were one thing and now you're
another so you became the other
unless gender fluidity is false
which is that what you believe
you're a fluid phobe
duly noted jamie
are you a cat no can you tell me what a
cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is oh
yes i mean i don't know if this is
lovely editing or if this is actually
how it went down but ask somebody to
define an animal yeah that really makes
sense asking someone to define an animal
that has nothing to do with the human
concept and language of gender and sex
is really not the clever move he thinks
it is i could bring up the example when
a well-known transphobe tried to define
a chair and then multiple people pointed
out to him that that definition could
also work for horses so well done a
horse is now a chair apparently
no see you're you're confused again uh
the point of the cat question was not to
quiz that person about the definition of
a cat
the point was to respond to the claim
that only women can know what women are
and first of all as i discovered at the
women's march that's not true because
lots of women don't know what women are
and second
you can absolutely know what something
is without being that thing
everybody knows what a cat is and yet
none of us are cats
i also know what a chinese person is
despite not being chinese i know what
planets and sandwiches and mice and
trees and mark wahlberg is despite the
fact that i'm not any of those things i
even know what a chair is that's not a
hard question
that's a seat built for one person
usually with four legs and a back
there you go that's a chair that
definition would not apply to horses
because horses aren't built okay
let's keep going i'm a biological woman
that medically transitioned to appear
like a male i will never
be a man oh
no abs no do not agree with that
99.99999
9
of trans men will very strongly disagree
with that statement don't know if that
person actually identifies as a trans
man by the sounds of it they are
assigned female at birth and
transitioned in the sense of taking
testosterone and living within society
as a man but yes sure for the purposes
of your seemingly transphobic
documentary go and find one of the very
very few trans people who holds these
kind of gender critical transphobic
views on trans people and include them
ignore the many thousands in the vast
vast majority of trans people who will
very strongly disagree with this very
very small number of trans people who
will say things like this
but who cares if scott nugent's views
are in the minority among trans people
trans people are in the minority among
the general population if you can
dismiss scott for being the minority
then can't i dismiss
you for being in the minority
also i did not ignore other trans people
we talked to lots of trans people in the
film some of whom you've already seen in
the trailer despite claiming that we
ignored them we tried to speak to many
more trans people but they refused to
speak to us and this is a pretty common
phenomenon right trans activists claim
that nobody will talk to us
oh why don't you talk to us and yet when
i try to talk to them they literally run
away
i mean literally get up and run away in
some cases okay uh jumping ahead now we
get to the part of the trailer where i'm
talking to a gender affirming
pediatrician
about the quote unquote gender affirming
about the chemical castration drugs she
gives to kids well i say i'm talking to
her about it but it's more accurate to
say that i tried to talk to her about it
she threatened to storm out of the
interview and as soon as i correctly
noted that the puberty blocker lupron is
used to chemically castrate pedophiles
and then that's what brings us to what
jamie has to say about all this let's
listen puberty blockers have actually
been used in cis kids with precocious
puberty for a very long time decades as
well decades precocious puberty being
when puberty starts too early so they
use puberty blockers to hold it off a
bit till the child is a more appropriate
age there has never been a fuss over cis
kids with early puberty having access to
puberty blockers in the same way that
there has been a fuss over trans kids
they're the same drugs they're used in
the same way to hold off puberty until a
child is ready to go through puberty no
one ever gave a [ __ ] about puberty
blockers until it became widely known
that they were used to help trans kids
okay jamie lean and close here so you
can you can hear this i want you to hear
it so pay close attention
precocious puberty is a physical
condition it's an ailment often caused
by tumors on the ovaries or adrenal
glands or by problems with the nervous
system or genetic syndromes precocious
puberty happens when a child's body is
doing what it is not supposed to do
naturally
that's why we call it precocious meaning
it's happening earlier than it's
supposed to
there are also direct physical
consequences to not treating precocious
puberty such as the potential for
stunted growth and other problems but
puberty blockers for quote trans kids
are used to treat quote unquote puberty
that is not precocious
there's no physical problem puberty is
happening exactly when it's supposed to
so on the one hand we have puberty
blockers used to treat early puberty in
children with a physical health
condition
on the other we have puberty blockers
used to stave off normal puberty in
children with no relevant physical
health condition
it's it's very similar to the difference
between top surgery for physically
healthy girls and a double mastectomy
for someone with breast cancer
and you don't see a difference in these
two scenarios
the difference is that they are
literally opposites of each other that's
the difference
i know it might be a little too subtle
for you phds not the most perceptive
bunch i've learned
is it transphobic to tell the truth the
interview is over let's turn off the
cameras excuse me well they're fair i
just wanted to know what is a woman and
you're not going to find out based on
what i'm saying would you ever want to
move to america
they say
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
honestly that felt like a hot mess and
was just filled with all of the
transphobic dog whistles and transphobia
that was thinly veiled as caring about
children truth is these people the
people with these views in the
transphobic views and making films like
this will not have had any concern for
the cis kids receiving the exact same
treatment and i'm not saying they should
have what i'm pointing out is that they
all of a sudden have concern and are
pouring money and resources into making
stuff like this to just
on an incredibly discriminated against
community within society why
it doesn't make sense to me there's just
a lot of fear-mongering going around
there's a lot of misinformation there's
a lot of half-truths there's a lot of
dog whistles and there's a lot of people
buying into it when in reality trans
people we just want to live our lives
okay trans kids deserve access to
transforming health care which again
just reminding you a majority of which
is purely just social and then the other
little bit is puberty blockers
so a lot to parse through here but i
couldn't help but note jaime that you uh
never said anything specifically about
the african tribe
i mean they were literally laughing at
the very idea of transgenderism and they
had a lot more to say which you'll see
in the film when it comes out on june
1st but you seem to let them off the
hook you called scott nugent at
transphobe and mia transphobe but you
seem somehow reluctant to call the call
out the bigotry of that group of
africans that i spoke to which is kind
of interesting
as for your claim at the end that uh
most trans affirming health care
quote-unquote for kids is social and the
rest is puberty blockers well
you're lying
as you know kids are getting surgery as
young as 14 or even younger potentially
they're chopping the breasts off of
minors that's part of the trans
affirming health care that you seem to
want to skate around
the puberty blockers we've already
covered they're not reversible they're
not safe and these are indeed the exact
same drugs they use to chemically
castrate convicted pedophiles
the social transition that you talk
about is designed to and almost always
has the effect of putting kids on the
path to medical transition a little
further down the line as you also know
so the distinction between social and
medical transition for kids is
misleading at best
but no surprise there as a trans
activist misleading people is what you
do best
speaking of which i noticed something
else jamie you you just gave a whole 10
minute response and yet you never did
actually respond to the question
kind of curious
your response could have been 15 seconds
you could have invalidated and debunked
the whole film humiliated me and scored
a major victory against transphobia
simply by providing a definition of
woman that's coherent and consistent
with gender ideology but you didn't
is that because you're
polite
so polite that you'll repeatedly accuse
me of bigotry and call the film a hot
mess but not provide the one thing that
would actually debunk the central
premise of the film
is it politeness or are you sitting on a
gigantic house of cards and you know it
and you know i know it but you don't
want anyone else to know
well i guess that's just another
question that i'm
asking even though i already know the
answer well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content